we know that a lot of our studs are
going to go to UFC and we love that
because that you know we're a new
commodity we're building a community
that we think is the long game that when
Fighters own something after 10 years
and you have all this stock we're going
to have the talent and we're going to
have the pool of people who the Accolade
of being a UFL champ hopefully it'll be
just as proud to say as a UFC it's not
going to happen overnight and we know
that we're not trying to compete with
that but we're building we think the
future have been made that it's more of
like an MBA model where the players are
taking care of the athletes are they see
more of a life after we want to be with
this and and so yeah we're not we don't
look at it as a competition there's
enough meat on the bone